Naše nejlepší klasické superpočítače jsou stále výkonnější,
a my se zlepšujeme ve výpočtech, včetně simulací systémů.
Ale simulace přírody je obecně velmi obtížný problém.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a dnes prozkoumáme jeden z algoritmů,
který by mohl umožnit simulaci přírody na kvantovém počítači.
Začněme příkladem a podívejme se na kofein.
Je to jednoduchá molekula.
Abychom reprezentovali energetickou konfiguraci jen jedné molekuly kofeinu,
potřebovali bychom přibližně deset na 48. mocninu bitů.
To je desítka s 48 nulami
a je to přibližně 10 % počtu atomů na Zemi.
A je to ještě horší.
Pokud máš 125 orbitalů a chceš uložit všechny možné
konfigurace, potřebuješ víc paměti
ve svém klasickém počítači, než je atomů ve vesmíru.
To je nemožné reprezentovat superpočítači.
Kvantové počítače ale dávají naději,
protože jsou ze své podstaty dobré při simulaci přírody.
Pro molekulu kofeinu by to znamenalo reprezentovat
systém pomocí 160 qubitů.
To zní mnohem zvládnutelněji.
Byly navrženy různé kvantové algoritmy, které umožňují
menším kvantovým počítačům heuristicky simulovat přírodu.
Přichází: variační kvantový eigensolver neboli VQE.
VQE je algoritmus, který běží částečně na kvantovém
počítači a částečně na klasickém počítači.
Umožňuje nám najít hodnoty, které řeší daný optimalizační problém.
VQE velmi úzce souvisí s jinými metodami zahrnujícími
variaci parametrů, jako je kvantový aproximační optimalizační algoritmus.
Identifikovat aplikace VQE ve svém oboru nebo výzkumu
je do jisté míry umění, ale existují volné směrnice.
Obecně platí, že VQE je použitelné na problémy, které lze formulovat
jako optimalizační problém se spojitými proměnnými.
To platí například pro velkou část kvantové chemie.
V chemii nás velmi často zajímá základní stav.
Základní stav je stav s nejnižší energií systému.
Aby VQE našlo energii základního stavu, prozkoumává
energii pro různé konfigurace systému
a hledá konfiguraci s nejnižší energií.
Na vysoké úrovni VQE přijme popis kvantového systému
a hledá nejnižší energii.
Dělá to tak, že mění konfiguraci systému.
Na začátku musíme zadat vhodný popis systému,
který kvantový počítač chápe, a sadu parametrů, které ho popisují
a které budou optimalizovány.
Kvantová část
algoritmu připraví systém do stavu
popsaného danou sadou parametrů a vypočítá energii.
Zatímco klasická část je zodpovědná
za optimalizaci těchto parametrů v každém kroku.
Tento kvantově-klasický proces se opakuje,
dokud nedosáhneme nejnižší energie.
Teď se přiblížme k tomu, co se děje pod kapotou.
Energetická konfigurace je typicky popsána Hamiltonianem,
což je obvykle opravdu velká matice.
V algebře bychom pro nalezení nejmenší vlastní hodnoty matice,
která odpovídá nejnižší energii systému,
jednoduše provedli rozklad na singulární hodnoty.
Jenže matice, se kterými budeme pracovat, jsou exponenciálně velké
a algebraicky je to exponenciálně obtížný problém.
Tento Hamiltonian musí být reprezentován ve formě,
které kvantový počítač rozumí.
Tedy přeložen z chemického jazyka do jazyka kvantových výpočtů.
Ale s detaily si dělej starosti.
Nakonec existují programovatelné způsoby, jak přeložit Hamiltonian obvykle
používaný v chemii do Hamiltonianu srozumitelného pro kvantový počítač.
Pak zadáme tento
Hamiltonian spolu s circuit, který nazýváme variační forma.
Výběr variační formy je do jisté míry umění.
Znovu,
reprezentuje náš nejlepší odhad toho, jaký by mohl být kvantový stav systému.
Tento variační circuit je parametrizován sadou parametrů theta,
a také zadáme počáteční volbu těchto parametrů.
Na základě toho kvantová část VQE:
připraví referenční stav, například nulový stav;
použije parametrizovaný quantum circuit, variační formu, k přípravě kvantového
stavu pro počáteční odhad parametrů na kvantovém počítači; a odhadne
energii odpovídající stavu vyhodnocenému přes Hamiltonian.
Tento odhad energie je pak předán
do klasického optimizéru, který najde novou sadu parametrů.
Parametry se vrátí zpět ke kvantovému solveru,
a celý proces se opakuje.
Kvantový počítač najde nový odhad energie,
klasický optimizér najde novou sadu parametrů a tak dále.
Opakujeme tento proces, dokud se řešení nekonverguje.
To znamená, dokud rozdíl výsledků mezi kroky není dostatečně malý
pro naše potřeby.
Na konci algoritmus vrátí tuto minimalizovanou energii.
Dobře, to je skvělé.
Ale možná se ptáš, jak víme, že to skutečně funguje
a že omylem nenajdeme nižší energii, než jakou hledáme?
To je skvělá otázka.
Ukazuje se, že nikdy nemůžeme odhadnout nižší energii.
Je to díky něčemu, čemu říkáme variační princip.
Variační princip říká, že největší dolní
mez energie systému je vždy jeho
nejnižší energie odpovídající základnímu stavu.
To znamená, že energie vyhodnocená v jakémkoli jiném stavu systému
bude vždy větší než nejnižší energie.
Proto pomocí VQE nikdy nemůžeme získat něco
nižšího než energie základního stavu.
Můžeme ale skutečně konvergovat k něčemu
vyššímu než je minimum, které hledáme.
To se často nazývá metastabilní řešení
a je to výzva, kterou se výzkumníci snaží řešit každý den.
VQE je užitečné, protože používá mělčí circuits
ve srovnání s jinými protokoly, které nám umožňují odhadnout energii základního stavu.
To ho dělá vhodným pro krátkodobý kvantový hardware.
V tomto videu jsme nahlédli do toho, co VQE dokáže a jak je postaveno.
Ale doporučuji ti prozkoumat Qiskit v tomto kontextu.
I když jsme stále na začátku naší kvantové cesty,
možná už ho najdeš užitečným pro problémy, které se snažíš vyřešit.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a toto byl přehled
algoritmu variačního kvantového eigensolverů.